good afternoon and welcome I'm Richard
Prem here as a director of the
science and humanities and the exciting
to have you here for our first event of
the new semester we have another event
coming up next week on Wednesday Jared
Diamond will be speaking in the Whitney
Humanities Center at on Wednesday
February 5 at 4 o'clock and he will be
talking about insights from individual
crises for understanding national crises
so that's at the Whitney down on Wall
Street in here on there on campus today
I'm excited to introduce David Haskell
our speaker this afternoon David Asst
professor of biology at swanee
University of the South and swanny
Tennessee he did his undergraduate
degree at Oxford with W D Hamilton and
Andrew pomian coughs key and went on to
a PhD with David Winkler at at Cornell
University where he worked on the
evolution of begging calls in Warblers
brilliant plumage and predation at the
nest and other topics in behavioral
ecology after join the faculty at swanee
he has continued his work on land use by
acoustics food production sustainability
in the Suwanee area and has even gotten
into family farming I first met David as
a as a as a graduate student and at
Cornell where he was one of the less
skeptical of the conversations I had
that day when I was talking about sexual
selection this was back in the mid 90s
maybe in early 90s and and since then
we've stayed in touch
somewhat distantly as guys do you know
Oh in meetings everyone so hey how's it
going but but but still aware of each
other's work and I remember most vividly
a meeting some not that many years ago
maybe five years ago at a bird meeting
where I was talking to David about my
hoped for direction in in taking an
aesthetic view of evolutionary biology
and and most of the people I was talking
to at time in biology would respond with
sort of let's change the subject of the
conversation quickly comment and
actually many of them still do but
but not David a was the first person who
really took that statement seriously and
recommended you know you really ought to
read some contemporary aesthetic
philosophy I think they're they're
really getting into some interesting
things and and it was with that
inspiration very very soon after that
conversation that I first made my first
dive into sterling library foraging
around on the shelves of aesthetic
philosophy looking for inspiration so
he's had that impact on my own work
which has certainly become central to
what I'm doing now
so the real reader in in my family is my
wife Ann and she has a voracious
interest in in fiction and nonfiction
consumes it at a rate that's sort of
alarming from my perspective I'm a slow
reader and there's never enough time to
read all this stuff I want to read so
but it's very frequent that you know in
the evening across the bed say you know
from her side of the pile the first idea
what you really ought to read this and
and it was then that she recently
proffered or because it was last spring
this is this this new little book the
forest unseen and I must admit that I
don't have enough time to read all the
nonfiction and fiction that I'd like and
and and I have a particular impatience
for a lot of popular science you know
III would admit I'm I'm an opinionated
guy and you know it's hard to please me
when some of these cutting corners and
puttin in their in their descriptions of
the complexity of the natural world and
I cracked it open I said wait a minute
I know this guy and then say well you
know not only is the is it is the book
cosmic but but but the science is great
I think I think you'll like it
right and of course and and of course
her immediate comment before I could
even think of it myself was you really
ought to bring him in for the Frankie
program right and so that's the
beginning of today's of today's talk I
found his book to be a spectacular thing
I'll have him he'll be describing it the
forest unseen published by Viking press
last year a sort of a new brand of
contemplative biology
and introspective and and and cosmic and
revelatory and and solid fantastic
science the the book is been highly
recognized it's the 2013 best book award
of the National Academies of science a
winner of the 2013 read environmental
writing award and the 2012 National
Outdoor Book Award for Natural History
literature was a finalist for the 2013
Pulitzer Prize and nonfiction I'll read
just one quote from Jim Gorman's review
in the Newark Times describing the book
as a welcome entry into the world of
David as a welcome entry into the world
of nature writers he thinks like a
biologist writes like a poet and gives
the natural world the kind of open
minded attention one expects from a zen
monk rather than a hypothesis-driven
scientist indeed there are many images
in the book that will stick with me
forever the idea of every plant cell
every freezing plant cell treating water
as carefully as a sword swallower and
the deer rumen as a as a luxury
accommodation for bacteria and fungi the
book is filled with that and it's really
a delight delight to read so I welcome
David Haskell
well thank you right for that very kind
introduction and for many years of
fruitful conversations and I'm glad I I
was able to contribute something some
little nuggets to your to your amazing
endeavors looking at the intersection
between art and biology and for any of
you who have not read his his which
journal is it in biology philosophy
aesthetics evolution art putting it all
together it's magnificent so I'm looking
forward to seeing that develop and thank
you to the Frankie program in science
and the humanities and the School of
Forestry and environmental studies for
your welcome and particularly also to
the Peabody Museum the staff at the
Museum I had a wonderful time this
morning getting up close and personal
with some of the ancestors with some of
the fossil collections they're a really
world-class and and it was a delight to
be able to take a little time to to look
at those up close and to hear some of
those stories so it's a great honor to
be here to share some of my work with
you thank you for braving the edge of
the Arctic vortex the polar vortex to be
here in this in this beautiful space I
feel like I finally understand what it
is to be a bark beetle to be sort of
inside the wood here under the cambium
layer moving through it's just it's
wonderful to be surrounded by so much
beautiful wood and and to share some
readings and some reflections that
ultimately come from an experience not
in the wood but sitting on the edge
hearing those scratching sounds from the
bark beetles coming coming from the
inside so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about my experience watching one
square meter of forest in southeast
Tennessee on the mountain slopes of
southeast Tennessee the book is called
the forest unseen I'm going to share a
few short readings give some reflections
and try and put things into some context
for you rather than just do readings or
just do lecture I'll mix it up a little
bit hopefully you know
and a helpful and helpful way so what
did I do
I walked late one winter on a mountain
slope this is the let me see if I can
find a laser pointer here you know I
will point with my hominid pointer so if
you look at the bright green Ridge
coming down here this is the western
escarpment of the Cumberland Plateau in
southeast Tennessee technically this is
the western edge of the Appalachian
Mountains the Smoky Mountains are
further east then there's a ridge and
valley and then you get up into that
Cumberland Plateau which extends from
Alabama all the way up into Kentucky
most of Eastern Kentucky is up on the
plateau I'm seeing I'm seeing lights
flickering here I wander through this
woods these woods until I found a flat
sandstone rock that looked like I could
sit on it with a reasonable degree of
comfort for a year thank you very much
okay we have free LASIK surgery for
anyone in the audience who wants it so
my little square meat was just around
this corner here here's the escarpment
sandstone coming down to limestone at
the bottom and then rich agricultural
land going out towards Nashville and
Huntsville if you're familiar with that
region so I sat down in an area I had
not seen before the square meter in
front of that about the size of a small
dining room table became my focus for
observations over at first a full year
and now many many years as I've returned
to this just to sit shut up for a change
and try and open my senses to see what
was happening in this one square meter
of forest my rules
don't kill things don't dig around too
much don't take things back to the lab
and just watch and use your senses a
notebook a hand lens and binoculars and
that's it now I'm not opposed to taking
things back to the lab and I do that a
lot in my scientific work and with
teaching and so on but for this
particular project
wanted to step into a different mode the
forest has the forest is you can see
here in the full looking across onto the
slope every tree here has a slightly
different shape slightly different color
to it texture this is an indication at
the very high richness of the the form
the floor of trees found here so we got
some some maples and probably that
golden one in the middle areas is a
Hickory and so on some mixed mythic
forest very high tree diversity as you'd
expect in the southern Appalachians down
below the deer haven't quite chewed it
all down to nothing alone some parts of
our region they really have cleared out
the understory but we've got lots of
dogwood although the dogwood has been
hit by a fungus lately spicebush further
down lots of ferns a very rich
particularly in the springtime flora of
herbaceous plants this and this is where
I was was close to where I was sitting
my guiding metaphor for the project was
the mandala so this is a sand mandala
you may have I'm sure I'm almost certain
that this is these are being constructed
at Yale here is that correct I'm seeing
some nodding so the Tibetan monks
particularly in North America now have
made a little business of going around
and constructing sand mandalas and and
they do that to share their culture and
to and also partly to fund the their
lives and to fund them from their
monastic work so this is about the same
size as the square metre that I observed
in the forest it's created over many
days by the monks letting tiny little
colored grains of sand out of brass
funnels forming this incredibly
intricate pattern across the table this
of course is an act of meditation it's
an act of training of the memory because
most of these patterns are
created from memory but ultimately it is
a recreation of the entire cosmos as
understood within that tradition lotus
flower symbol of Buddha at the center
gates on the side representing different
ways on the path to enlightenment and so
the whole world is seen through this
small circle of sand we've heard that in
the Western tradition of course Julian
of Norwich saw the whole universe she
was a Christian can temple that in a
tiny hazelnut Blake seeing the world in
a grain of sand and a heaven in a wild
flower so what I did was to take this
challenge coming from particularly the
religious traditions the contemplative
challenge to sit down and pay attention
and to draw the zone of attention in
rather than trying to zoom around all
over the world and look at the
particularity and within religious
traditions the claim is that
paradoxically you then see further by
focusing in a physical analogy is a
pinhole camera a pinhole camera only
works if the hole in the front of the
camera is a pinprick it doesn't work if
it's a big hole so let's get more light
in here more focus and make the hole
bigger it doesn't work it's got to be a
pinhole and so again perhaps it's not
quite so paradoxical and in a physical
realm but by drawing in you see more
crisply and and further excuse me
so here's a detail of the the sand
patterns and of course when when this is
finished what happens to the sand
Mandella the tibet Mendell it is swept
up and the jumbled sands are then cast
out into running water so it is also a
symbol of impermanence and these
pictures in some way violate temporarily
that impermanence this Mandela does not
exist anymore it's it's sands have been
dispersed however on the longer time
frame of course the pixels and they're
the little electrical arrangements that
are holding this on flickr and on the
flash drive here that will all be
- and so this mandala is not permanent
in any sense even though it's being
captured and it's stored in the cloud
here for just a little while so I said I
tried to apply this in an ecological
context I was not looking for for
religion going into the woods I was
trying to apply my senses to this world
and here is another sand mandala this is
just a few square inches of a sandstone
block close to where I set there were
probably a dozen species of lichen and
moss on this one tiny patchy and so and
just a few square inches you've got
enormous incredible history embedded and
that's each one of these creatures has
owned its own history and story probably
within the mosses you've got all kinds
of tardigrades and other animals
clinging around in there and this these
inches few inches are also connected up
to the rest of us through the rain that
comes in the mercury and the other
things that are raining down onto this
onto this Mandella through our
industrial innovations so the square
meter for me served as a device to focus
my attention a way of structuring the
narrative of the book and hopefully it
provided also an intriguing hook when
you're writing about something as
seemingly diffused and amorphous as
biology modern biology humanities
relation to the world it's helpful to
have some way of organizing this and
then something that people are going to
hear the soundbite and think that sounds
crazy I want to follow up on that so
this guy sat and watched one square
meter what's that all about and so it
also serves as a hook for the book that
runs against the grain of the
hypermobility and the globalization that
of course we're all embedded now and I
think these two things speed each other
there's nothing wrong with mobility and
globalization and if it's done right but
unless we know our homes our places we
have nothing to offer that global
conversation so sitting down and paying
attention to home whether it's
biological home or cultural home or the
intersection among all of those things
I think it's part of what this book is
offering so why did I undertake this
project first reason was I wanted to go
to the forest without an agenda for a
change as a scientist and a teacher I
seldom did that I go out in the woods a
lot but there's a lesson plan today
we're going to talk about the carbon
cycle we're going to take these
measurements well today I'm collecting
these snails because I need to get some
mitochondrial information out of them
and so forth there's a plan an agenda a
lens a preconceived idea of what I am
going to encounter out there and those
are wonderful it's a good thing for it
scientists have a hypothesis it's a
great thing for a teacher to have a
lesson plan usually I want it to be in a
different mode to leave those agendas
behind and to just see where it where
those observations might take me now of
course we can never enter the world
without preconceived ideas we have ideas
in our heads we have emotional
commitments we have sensory filters
there's our physiology and also our
memory and our training give us all so I
can't escape from those but I wanted to
set step aside for the ones that I could
and then perhaps see the remaining ones
more clearly and we'll get to that to
that thing here in just just a moment
so this approaches is rooted in my
personal experience of meditation I have
a practice usually that I'm fairly good
at sticking out of just sitting down and
being quiet for a couple of times a day
and watching the breath and in the
practice of meditation the idea of
letting go of judgment and just being
there for whatever arises without
judgment without clinging or without
pushing away that's what meditation is
all about I'm applying that in some
sense in a much easier context because
I'm not letting I'm attending to the
senses of this really amazing forest so
there's a there's a there's a lot of
great stuff to be looking to be looking
at and attending to whereas in silent
meditation with your eyes closed it's
all the garbage coming up in your head
that you would rather not be aware of
but there is a strong parallel and in
fact
practicing meditation was one of that
one of the inspirations for for this
book so there were some personal reasons
there are also some professional reasons
after my watch I wanted to tell some of
those stories to share what I had seen
so I would run to the to the library to
read up a little bit more about what
people had written and published on this
particular organism or ecological
interaction that I had observed and then
I wrote a series of essays to tell those
stories in a way that I hoped would be
interesting and compelling and get the
stories that are buried in scientific
papers in conference reports in the
backs of specialist brains get those
things out there
hold them up and celebrate them in a way
that I wish we had more of in our
culture you switch on the TV you pick up
the newspaper even the highbrow
newspapers and most of it seems
completely disconnected to what I'm
really passionate about which is twigs
and salamander skin and things that are
actually interesting and important and
determine the future right so how does a
carbon get drawn out from the from the
atmosphere
twigs those bud scale scars measuring
that you know how far a twig grew each
year by looking at its bud scale scars
that's the ledger of our future if we're
looking at how much carbon is being
drawn in and then of course the
acceleration of carbon back to the
atmosphere is all through the
particularity of the microbial community
in the soil so even those grand
questions like climate change and global
biogeochemical cycles are rooted in the
particularity zuv things that I think we
would do well as a culture to attend to
a little more and of course these are
familiar themes right we hear every week
there's another survey that comes out
that says this country beats our young
school children in math comprehension or
in biology and so forth and we're
falling behind and so forth yes science
literacy and Natural History literacy is
is an important issue but for me there's
also an aesthetic component to this
because the Darwinian worldview the
ecological worldview
gives us a lens to through which to see
the world and that lens explodes beauty
when you can look at a tree or a bird
and see the ancient history and
understand its relations to other
species around it
your world is enriched compared to seen
as just a flat up there a bunch of trees
well that's just a bunch of birds out
there and that's often how they're
portrayed even in the the more nature
oriented parts of the media so
connecting to stories of ecology and
evolution can help I hope people connect
into some of the incredible beauty and
fascination and also pain in this world
now with one come comes the other so let
me just start my discussion of the book
with a problem that arises when we talk
about other speeches the species or
tried about right about nature a number
of literary literary critics have argued
that much nature writing falls into a
dangerous trap and that's the trap of
believing that we can transparently
represent nature as we're scribing on
our pages they claim and I agree that we
can't write about an experience of being
immersed in nature because our thoughts
about the experience are mediated
through our idea of what nature is and
often that idea is that nature is a
sublime place where we're going to
experience some oneness or connection or
relaxation or transcendence and as a
biologist I agree with that but I would
extend the argument in two ways one is
we come with a lot of sensory and
physiological filters that mean that
even if our ideas aren't getting in the
way our sense organs are providing a
particular window that we need to try to
step out of and the second thing is we
can examine the origins of that lack of
transparency and those origins of course
our evolutionary so when we look at a
tree through a hazy
the halting windows and these windows
are very clear actually the literary
critics wouldn't like they're very clear
there's no distortion it's not much mud
on them but if they were we why don't we
look at the tree and the window and the
mud on the window and those little
ripples in the in the old poured glass
there and so that's my solution is
address this head-on say yes you're
right
let's look at both of these things and
not make the mistake of saying well we
can't no we can't write about trees
because it's all just our idea of tree
well no I believe there is another being
out there that we need to attend to
however hazily and imperfectly so let me
share a short reading from a chapter and
I'm going to jump to different parts of
this chapter so that we're not here for
several hours just two or three and when
I try and do this so to discuss another
creature to discuss the impossibility of
actually knowing that other creature and
to do it in a way that people might find
worth reading so that and that last part
is the hardest January 21st the
experiment a polar wind rips across the
mandala streaming through my scarf
pushing an ache into my jaw
not counting the windchill it's 20
degrees below freezing in these southern
forests such cold is unusual typical
southern winters cycle between thor's
and mild freezes with deep chills
arriving for a few days each year
today's cold will take the Mandela's
life to its physiological limits I want
to experience the cold as the forest
animals do without the protection of
clothes on a whim no reenactment here on
a whim I throw my gloves and hat on the
frozen ground the scarf follows quickly
I strip off my insulated overalls shirt
t-shirt trousers the first two seconds
of the experiment are surprisingly
refreshing a pleasant coolness after the
he clothes then the wind blasts away the
illusion and my head is fogged with pain
the heat streaming out of my body
scorches my skin a chorus of Carolina
chickadees provides the accompaniment to
this absurd striptease the birds danced
through the trees like sparks from a
fire careening through twigs they rest
no more than a second on any surface
then shoot away the contrast on this
cold day between the chickadees
liveliness and my physiological
incompetence seems to defy nature's
rules
small animals should be less able to
cope with the cold than their larger
cousins small animals cool rapidly
because they have proportionally lots
more body surfaced and body volume and
so that launches us into a discussion of
biogeography and why animals tend to be
larger at the higher high latitudes and
so forth then the wind gusts hard and
the burning sensation in my skin surges
then a deeper pain starts something
behind my conscious mind is trapped and
alarmed my body is failing after just a
minute in this winter chill yet I weigh
10,000 times more than a chickadee
surely these birds should be
extinguished in seconds so there's me
there's the chickadee this makes no
sense whatsoever great introduction to a
little lesson in ornithology hear about
shivering those huge great big
pectoralis muscles we have no muscle
that's equivalent they shiver that they
get a blast of of heat through their
bodies their eyesight as Rickon can tell
us now in four dimensions with a great
model they see colors we don't see and
they see combinations of colors we don't
see they have visual acuity that is much
higher than us so where we see a twig
they see this flaking amazing contortion
with little spider eggs and hidden in
seconds
so they can find food in a forest they
live in a different sense of a universe
and ours in a different forest in some
ways so yes they can find food where
there is none for us as I stand shaking
fear surfaces I panic and dress as fast
as I can my hands are numb I grasped my
clothes with difficulty fumbling with
zippers and buttons my head aches as if
my blood pressure suddenly soared my
only desire is to move quickly I walk
jump wave my arms my brain signals make
hate fast the experiment lasted only a
minute just one ten thousandth of the
duration of this week of arctic air yet
my physiology reals my head pounds lungs
can't grasp enough air and my limbs seem
paralysed had the experiment continued
minutes longer my core body temperature
would have dropped into hypothermia
stripped of my clever cultural
adaptations to the cold
I'm revealed as a tropical Abe
profoundly out of place in the winter
forest the chickadees insouciant mastery
of this place is humbling and the
chickadees of course also have it rough
because a lot of them won't make it
they've mastered it but many won't make
it and so these cold winter nights where
the chop comes down into the chicken
particularly population which then means
that come summertime there's a super
abundance of insects in these northern
forests and that powers and migration up
from the tropics and so from these
particular things like chickadee
physiology and not being able to make it
through in the winter and populations
being kept pretty low we have global
level phenomena like bird migration
emerging from that so we discussed
torpor and other phenomena and conclude
with my own physiological inadequacy in
the cold has its origins in natural
selection I'm out of place at the icy
Mandela
because my ancestors have dodged
selection for cold hardiness humans
evolved from apes that live for tens of
millions of years in tropical Africa
keeping cool was a much bigger challenge
than keeping warm so we have few bodily
defenses against extreme cold when my
ancestors left Africa for northern
Europe they brought with them fire and
clothes carrying the tropics to the
temperate and polar regions this
cleverness produced less suffering and
fewer deaths unquestionably good
outcomes but comfort sidestepped natural
selection we are condemned by our skill
with fire and cloth to be forever out of
place in the winter world so what
happens with a reflection on chickadees
the forest becomes a mirror and we see
ourselves a little more clearly our
limitations and we also see the ways
that we can we're held in this tension
if you like between being able to relate
to the chickadee a blood cousin in the
vertebrate clan and also the art of
distance between us and them it's
unimaginable I can't I can perhaps
imagine what it's like to have one extra
color receptor I can't imagine what it's
like when all those color receptors in
my eyes interact produce a subjective
experience of seeing a twig in the way
that chickadee would and that's an
important thing I think to hold up in
so-called nature writing is that yes we
have these emotional intellectual
reactions to the world but there is a
limit there to how much we can how far
are imaginative can pass imaginative
capacity excuse me can carry us into
understanding these other creatures so
it's not just other species we learn
about it's ourselves and this is where
first-person narrative taking our
clothes off in the woods and so try to
explain what that's all about and
scientific knowledge can merge and I
think that is a place where often nature
writing science communication works so
might watching the forest also quickly
brought into focus other
imitations of our ideas about nature
from the very first day I saw that the
forest was ruled by the inconspicuous
proletariat the 99% of biology where the
1% the big lumbering creatures lichens
tiny worms fungal strands the microbial
community and the many unseen
physiological and physical processes
that determine how plants and animals
and fungi like microbial communities are
going to be structured and how they're
going to how they're going to play out
through time like the difference between
a vascular system of hickories and
maples explaining that patchy
variegation on the mountain side in the
springtime where one tree emerges a
month before the other the hygroscopic
spittle of ticks that they drool down
onto their chins and thereby drink water
out of the air as they're waiting
waiting waiting for the vertebrate to
come by to come by and get them out of
these seaming my new show the whole wild
world is woven too many w's there may be
and that's what this book is partly
about is taking up those humble little
creatures holding them up and gazing at
them even the tick's eye-to-eye and of
course out there in the main cultural
depictions of ecology we have polar
bears eating seals and redwood trees
standing majestic but inert that that's
a small part of biology and those trees
are in fact not in that living creatures
continually dynamically involved with
their surroundings so of course getting
beyond this distorted view of the
community of life can help us become
more ecologically literate it can also
and this is perhaps a little less
obvious to focus on the large cute
mammals often has a hidden message and
that is that nature is not here nature
is somewhere else usually the other side
of the world and a Nature Reserve
it's not here so in reinforce
this view of us and them nature and
humanity rather than what we know from a
biological point of view is that that
division is an illusion a falsehood so
even the word environment from the
French over all the environment the
surroundings the other than me that that
doesn't make sense anymore everything we
know about human physiology now and and
the world suggests that that the
environment that truly does not exist at
least in the way that it's at least in
the etymology that has come to us now so
I tried to give many examples in this
book of the and hold up and celebrate
these these fascinating creatures how
noses as microbial detectors the biology
of grazing snails and how that interacts
with with bird breeding and acid rain
I'm going to share just one short
reading here appropriate to the day
perhaps and that is about winter plants
and rick has already mentioned one of
the little metaphors in here and what
I'm trying to do here is first to help
people see what mostly we walk by and
not even see and then perhaps second to
feel some curiosity or maybe even some
wonder about it so we're in January
still the life filled exuberance of the
birds contrasts with the mandalas plants
their gray branches and bare twigs offer
a scene of desolation death juts from
the snow fallen partly decayed maple
branches and frayed stubs of leaf cup
stems protrude each stem rained with a
circle of sublimated snow that reveals
the dark litter below winter appears to
have delivered a thorough defeat yet
life persists their shrubs and trees are
not the skeletons they appear to be
every twig and trunk is wrapped in
living tissue
unlike birds that survived by fighting
the cold with food one from winters type
plants somehow endure without recreating
an internal summertime the birds
survival is astonishing but the plants
resurrection after a full surrender is
so far removed from human experience
that it edges into scandal the dead
especially the frozen dead should not
return but return they do plants survive
in the same way that a sword swallower
survives with careful preparation and
meticulous attention to sharp edges
plant physiology can generally cope with
mere chilling unlike the chemical
reactions that sustain humans plant
biochemistry can run at many different
temperatures and it does not fail when
cooled but when cooling turns to
freezing problems start expanding ice
crystals will puncture tear and destroy
the delicate inner architecture of cells
plants in winter must therefore swallow
tens of thousands of blades keeping each
one away from their fragile heart plants
start their preparations several weeks
ahead of the first freezes they move DNA
and other delicate structures to the
centres of their cells and wrap them in
cushioning the cells get fatiah and the
chemical bonds in these fats change
shape to make them flu it in cold
temperatures the membranes around cells
become leaky and flexible the
transformed cells are padded and limber
able to absorb ices violence without
harm and they follow a couple more pages
of reveling in plant physiology and we
conclude the impression of desolation in
the mandala is superficial within the
bounds of this one square meter are
hundreds of thousands of plant cells
each one wrapped into itself intensified
in its withdrawal the quite gray
exterior of plants like gunpowder
belies the energy that is latent here
so although titmice and other birds give
a vigorous display of life in January
they are trifles compared to the power
stored in the client plants when spring
sparks the mandala the energy released
will carry the whole forest birds
included through another year so a
preacher of twigs is what I'm what I'm
trying to become here and I hope is
you're wandering the streets of New
Haven you'll you'll look at a load of
twigs and think of the all those many
many ice blades and particularly in
spring when that emergence comes out we
can understand it but on another level
we cannot because it's so far out of the
bounds of human experience another theme
in the book is the power and the
ubiquity of biological networks and I'll
introduce this and do a short reading
for this and then give some some
reflections on this this came about
sitting in the woods on my rock in the
fall so I had a practice of sipping
melting into the rock and just being
still for hours on end and when you do
that and those of you who've had this
experience you know that the other
creatures forget that you're there you
become a rock or at least many of the
creatures do and then things start
having birds walk across your feet the
chipmunks come and check you out and so
forth so I'm sitting very still and a
white-tailed deer walks up to me and
comes really close before she realizes
takes alarm gives her alarm snort and
bounds away through the woods coming
across a seated human in the woods in
the fall in Tennessee not a good outcome
for a deer people ever have a vigorous
love of venison so she took alarm rut
ran away and that's not remark right
deer everywhere these days and we often
hear their alarm snorts although some
are so tame that they don't even bother
snorting they just try and shoe you out
of that there were
but because I've been sitting there
quietly I could hear how the rest of the
woods responded that alarm call was like
a rock thrown into a lake and the waves
spread out from there
so the Chipmunks immediately chip they
pick up the alarm the Chipmunks further
out pick up the alarm the ones further
out and a wave of chickadee alarm calls
spreads out through the woods the grey
squirrels and the trees do the same
thing they start alarm calling alarm
alarm whooping whooping the width rush
further down the slope gives its alarm
and spreads out so there is an acoustic
network in the woods that we are mostly
unplugged from but this the organisms in
the wood particularly the mammals and
the birds are attuned to this they know
what is happening 500 meters away
because they can hear the newswire the
rippling coming through there literally
the tweet must fear the original the
original tweet Mystere and so they're
plugged into the social network and for
them if they miss the status update
they're not just out of it the death the
sharp-shinned hawk came you weren't
paying attention to the alarm calls that
we've been giving over here
you're the sharp-shinned Hawks lunch or
dinner time snack and now of course
hunters and and other people who've been
to the woods and many cultures have done
that done this for hundreds if not
thousands of years have tuned in to
these sounds we have the ability to tune
back in just by paying attention to that
acoustic network and so now when I'm in
the woods I know when people are coming
down the hiking trail further down the
mountain because two or three minutes
before the humans arrive the chitlin
start up with their particular alarm
call a bow wave has preceded the arrival
of the people and the people usually
arriving in agitation and talking loudly
as they're hiking which is our nature as
primates those of you who've been to
places with wild primate cousins know
they're usually they're not quiet
they're up there gossiping and cussing
each other and throwing fruit around and
so on so so we come from not very
stealthy lineage
so I have some sympathy for some make
I'll get really annoyed when the
students it just being too loud in the
woods and I sympathize it's good to get
a practice of slowing down and being
quiet but partly that's what it's like
you know you're an 18 year old primate
what are you gonna do when you're a
bunch of other 18 year old some of whom
you you really are very interested in
you're gonna be loud and you're gonna be
joking and so on so that's that's what
the Chipmunks are paying attention to
and of course we are predatory organisms
so they want to know what we're we're up
to so there's an acoustic Network and of
course that then leads into a
description of the other kinds of
networks in the forest
I'll read three paragraphs here about a
plant network and this book came out was
written a few years ago and so now those
of you who are plant physiologist will
now know that this has been what I write
about here has been expanded many fold
and we now know even more amazing ways
in which plants plants and network
through airborne chemicals the animals
acoustic network has an invisible analog
among the forests plants when insects
chew on leaves they trigger a
physiological reaction from the host
plant that not only deters further
damage to the host but also alerts
neighboring plants damaged leaves turn
on genes that produce a flush of
chemicals some of these defensive
chemicals evaporate and perfume the air
around wounded plants the wet interior
of neighboring plants leaves are soaked
in these molecules and like aroma in a
human nose the molecules dissolve and
move into the surrounding cells here the
chemicals turn on some of the same genes
that produce the defensive chemicals in
the original plant on wounded plants
around the damaged colleague therefore
become less palatable to insects the
trees are listening and when I sit or
walk in the forest I'm not a subject
observing objects
I enter the mandala and AM caught up in
webs of communication networks of
relationships whether or not I am
we're of it I change these webs by
alarming a dear startling a chipmunk
stepping on the living leaf dissociated
observation is not possible in the
mandala the webs changed me also every
inhalation carries hundreds of airborne
molecules into my body these molecules
are the aroma of the woods
the combined fragrance of thousands of
creatures some aromas are so pleasing to
us that we've domesticated them
extracting perfumes at least one such
perfume jasmine 8 is an alarm chemical
the signaling danger among plants but
these perfumes are the exception most of
the forest molecules bypassed my sense
of smell and dissolve directly into my
blood entering my body and mind below
the level of consciousness the effects
of our chemical interpenetration that
plant aromas are largely unstudied we
haven't stooped to take seriously the
possibility that the forest or the lack
of it might be part of our being yet
forest lovers know very well that trees
affect our minds the Japanese have named
this knowledge intended to into a
practice shinrin yoku or bathing in
forest air it seems that participation
in the mandalas community of information
may bring us a measure of well-being at
the wet chemical core of ourselves so
when I leave Yale I will not carry just
memories I will carry physical bonds to
Yale to the trees to this building I
will carry this auditorium bound into my
bloodstream for better or worse LEED
Platinum so whatever is outgassing out
of here is probably not doing me too
much harm
yeah and I'll enjoy the high the buzz
from the from the carpet so it's what we
reduced to now carpet huffing so this
gets to what I think is is a theme in
biology that is
starting to explode but we haven't quite
figured out what it means and that is
realizing that the self is an illusion
and what really matters is the network
is the relationships and the connections
among what we formerly would have
referred to as cells now every day
there's some new study about the human
microbiome coming out that it makes us
happy or sad or sick or fat well then
those studies certainly are going to be
superseded as we as we learn more but
the key message is that I'm not a self
I'm a walking community and the texture
of my feelings that of my mind emerged
from the interactions of multiple
different evolutionary lineages gathered
up into this temporary bundle that I
would presume to call me and so that
most private place our consciousness is
a product of a network is a product of
an ecological community so the self in
that sense doesn't work anymore
the self as a gene doesn't look any a
gene isn't a gene a gene is part of a
community of interactions with proteins
and other bits of nucleic acid and to
understand that gene you have to
understand that network it's not so the
the old views or one gene one enzyme
when we're done doesn't hold up anymore
trees of course so seemingly separate
with their separate trunks wide through
the Ethernet below ground in there and
then mycorrhizae but also above-ground
through sharing chemicals and
information their leaves are loaded with
endophytes
so an oak leaf is not an oak leaf it's a
community of different kinds of cells
that we summarize by calling it an oak
leaf but there are actually there's a
whole ecological community in there even
the thing that sits at the core of
biology
what is biology the study of life what
is life self-replicating organisms the
self it's right there and yet the models
of the evolution of the early evolution
of life now they're talking about
networks it's not a molecule that self
replicates to make another molecule its
molecule a brings molecule B and to
brings molecule C into being recreates
molecule a it's the network that
replicates itself and competes with
other networks that seems to be the
current model says how life may have
gotten started at the very origins of
that that replicating process so the
self we have to leave behind and move on
to thinking about networks and I think
we're going to need some help in doing
this because biologists are not good at
thinking out of the atomistic view where
you have separate individuals that
jostle around those jostling
interactions of atoms determine natural
selection ecology and that's the
fundamental way in which natural
selection is usually defined separate
individuals interact and then you get an
evolutionary process emerging from that
physicists on the other hand have had
for many years to talk about light
wave-particle both depends on the
situation now a forest is also in a
wave-particle situation it's a
collection of individuals and it's
Network two contradictory mutually
incompatible views that are both true at
the same time or in both true in
different contexts and I would also say
that we need to listen to the religious
traditions not to get converted to their
metrical physical world views but
because these traditions are places
where humans very smart humans have been
thinking for thousands of years about
the self and the community and the
network and Confucianism you're defined
not by yourself but by your relation to
others in Buddhism the notion of the
self as an illusion is a foundational
part of that religion even in
Christianity Orthodox Christianity where
there is an active mystic view of the
soul in some respects at the heart of
Christianity the Trinity three-in-one
one in three it's just like a
biochemical Network so I'm not sure my
theologian colleague they're going to
want to hear that but I do think that
that there are some languages ways of
thinking that could be helpful here not
because we got to buy into the
supernatural
this group or that group but because
these are other really smart people who
struggled with this and could perhaps
say biology a lot of work as we move
into this this leaving behind the
optimistic world and moving into the
networked world we're also ready to do
this I think because of what's in our
pockets right our phones so in the in
the 70s and 80s I had a little computers
and the computer was the computer
it was the atomistic world now my phone
is almost irrelevant what's relevant and
can be monetized and spied on that is
the network of connections that I've
formed and what's being sent up into the
cloud so we understand networks and how
fundamentally different they are now
because they've come into our lives but
those things in our pockets are really
echoes of the three and a half billion
year old network that we've we're part
of and so that to me that's a very
interesting place for further
conversations among those disciplines
let me conclude with a few short
reflections about the roots of this book
and those roots art Natural History the
study of the particularity of our homes
now natural historians ramble all over
the world but often that passion is
based on attention to home and as we
know in the Academy as in the culture
Natural History is not being faring so
well lately
in fact many of the courses and programs
that have been offered in this and many
universities are being been gotten rid
of and so what what is a value of
Natural History education and enthusiasm
fit and of an enthusiasm for Natural
History I would say the two classes of
benefits one of practical benefits we
can't help but need to manage and
conserve the world and if we're going to
be stage directors we need to know the
script and the players we were going to
put on Midsummer Night's Dream here we
need to know who puck and Oberon were
now we're going out to the management
situation where we know the big ideas we
we've never heard of puck and we
wouldn't be able to identify Park
if parks came and sat right in front of
us puck is a character and made so much
drink so and the details of this of
course matter if we if we don't get
those details wrong through the more
global models the universal models which
are important will fail knowledge of
natural history I think also has some
political implications for the current
debate about human sexuality at the
Supreme Court the argument was made
against gay marriage was that we need a
marriage founded in nature the Tennessee
legislature put for legislation saying
you cannot teach kids in school anything
except natural reproduction those
arguments are completely uninformed by
any knowledge of what the trees are
doing out there all the snails let alone
the biology and the behavior of our
closest cousins
now biology is not going to tell us in
an unambiguous way this is how you
should behave as an individual as a
society around sexuality for humans but
what biology can do in Natural History
can do is falsify some of the arguments
that are still being vigorously made in
the highest court of the land about the
nature of sexuality in the world and so
some attention to the spring blooms of
the cherries along the mall in in
Washington DC and the sex changing slip
Olympics just down just down the Potomac
would do us all some good I think so
there are practical benefits I also and
they're important I also think that
paying attention to the ecological
particularity zuv home has value that
transcends practical utility if we take
Darwin seriously those trees those
chickadees those fungi out there are ken
there are blood relations and the rocks
are also our kin in a not in a
biological sense but in a sense of
coming out of the same stars and
physical processes so we belong in this
world and just like coming home for
Thanksgiving
- no the family might have some inherent
value now in biology some of the
families going to try and kill you the
parasites and so forth but still there
may be value and leaning into that I'd
say beyond Thanksgiving dinners and
enriching lives by knowing communities
and family members
I'd say Natural History offers a
challenge to the Academy mobility and
I'm the great example of this mobility
is the name of the game in academia
right you go to high school one place
undergrad another grad school here a
postdoc first job second job all over
for me two continents three different
countries so the questions you ask have
to be unrooted you have to be able to
put them in the u-haul and move across
the country with them and that's okay
there are great questions that are
unrooted questions but what it does is
that those questions that are routed
don't work anymore
because that's not going to work for
your career so what gets counted as
knowledge has changed within the Academy
so for our ancestors local knowledge was
the important knowledge because it was
related directly to survival now local
knowledge is considered that's what you
do when you become Deadwood or you've
run out of real good ideas and so forth
so and we see this now being pushed down
to the low levels through these next
generation science standards which I
think have a lot of great things in them
but you will find no encouragement to
know the biodiversity of home in those
next generation science standards that
our school kids will be living with now
for many years rather you'll find
encouragement to evaluate competing
design solutions for developing managing
and utilizing energy and mineral
resources based on cost benefit ratios
evaluate or refine technological
solutions that reduced impacts of human
activities on natural systems those are
both great activities but if we have an
educational system that explicitly
mentions geoengineering the planet and
extracting mineral resources to impose
costs on someone else it's a fundamental
part of educate
but has no encouragement to know the
local stories of home the ecological
stories of home or the the the nature of
biodiversity around home or globally I
think we will have an impoverished
education and the fruits of that are
unlikely to be sweet fruits
therefore Natural History's challenge to
the Academy is can the particularity zuv
place of home matter and this isn't an
argument for narrow provincialism the
universal questions are important those
great ideas are Darwin how whether they
come from they came from the
particularity of beetles and bird
specimens and so my argument is that
there's focusing in on one square metre
or on one beetle through that
particularity you can get to the
universal the to feed each other and
what we've done in education is focused
mostly on one end and loft off the other
so I conclude by inviting you to
consider how you might conduct your own
experiment either for yourself or with
your family or students to construct
your own pinhole camera to commit to
giving repeated attention to a tree a
patch of sky this community of squirrels
in the suburban yard find your Mandella
find your place and watch it for years
enter into relationship with that one
space that one place and see where it
takes you and as TS Eliot wrote be still
and wait
and I think I will close that and thank
you for your attention